the time being 10 15. I like to call
capital budget overview committee to
order
um
and the first order of business
is the acceptance of the minutes of the
September 19 2022 meeting
are there any corrections errors or
Omission or that anybody noticed in the
minute says distributed
seeing none I would take a motion to
approve those minutes Joe moved
been moved by representative Petrie
um and seconded by Senator Daniels that
the minutes be approved there any
discussion seeing none in all those
opposed nay the eyes have it and then
the minutes are approved we have no old
business we have no new business we have
no miscellaneous business
um we do have some informational items
that were passed out
um is there any desire on the parts of
members of the committee to hear about
see not
or some Graham you may want to hear
about the late informational item
just so they can be explained a little
bit more
which the uh the one about the rail oh I
was getting into that okay okay I met
the ones that were passed out
okay I'm seeing none on the the um
the ones that were listed on the agenda
I did ask
um a representative of the Saint
Lawrence in Atlantic rail to come give
us a very brief description of what is
going on
with a a grant proposal for that
Railroad and is it is
cap22-19 informational
and if you would
do this the reason I bring this up is
because it it is going forward and I'm
looking around and several of the people
sitting around this table will be back
next year so I think that it was
important to understand what is going on
and what the impact might be on money
uh thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee first of all I'd like to thank
the
chair of the Senate Transportation
committee and the chair of the Public
Works committee for submitting us a
support letter uh for this grant the
grant is called
if you could identify yourself with Paul
Wall switch Gallagher Callahan gatrell
represent the St Lawrence Atlantic
Railroad
the Grant and I'll just read it to you
is a Consolidated rail infrastructure
and safety improvements program better
known as Chrissy
um we're applying St Lawrence Atlantic
has got the States of Maine
New Hampshire and Vermont making an
application to finish up the remainder
of the improvements needed to bring this
rail up to uh the guy call it
um 286 pound that really means what you
can carry on the rail right now we're
only allowed to carry 263 pounds uh it's
a full car and it's really the modern
businesses when they're locating in a
state I want to see what you have for
rail service and we don't have adequate
rail in the North Country and
this rail was first started
before the Saint Lawrence Atlantic
Seaway was ever built the only way you
get material from a product from Canada
to the rest of the world was to come
down to these this they call it the
Saint Lawrence Atlantic railroad it
comes down to down to its Portland and
you get to warm water go up to Nova
Scotia and come down to uh even to
Portsmouth
this is the rail has been you know the
last time it was improved back in the
40s so we needed to get improvements
we've been doing it over the years and
in New Hampshire we have seven miles
left to get uh to bring it up to 286
pound Vermont has
a portion and Maine has the portion to
get it up to 286 and when having modern
uh real and the reason it's important is
when
the be
business
I know they got their business and
economic affairs
people go out and try to recruit
companies to the North Country the first
thing to look is what do you have for
transportation
and they look at the railences you've
got an Antiquated real we can't get a
full car into into our companies up here
so we've been and I've been working
around since 2010 and we've got it down
in New Hampshire we need about
seven uh
seven million dollars approximately the
Vermont needs 3.6 and may need 7.6 so we
it was the first time we're going to get
three states making an app a joint
application and as I said the Chrissy
Grant people they thought this is an
excellent project
uh and so we're going to see what we can
get for money
but I provided was you know again I want
to show you the map that's how that's
what the St Lawrence Atlantic railroad
comes down from Canada or into Vermont
and into
New Hampshire and Maine uh right now
we're we're good up until
we can get to Stratford in New Hampshire
we're up to Stratford New Hampshire uh
or they call it a maple Town New
Hampshire
is the uh that's the area we're up to
good Rail and then we need another seven
miles to go to the Vermont border
and
the next map
is just showing where the product is
coming to that area we've been keeping
track of what's trying to get up into
that into the North country
and item number three is the Tri-State
Regional Real upgrade project good
explanation of the rail
and again the number five is
um sort of a history of
public private partnership that was
started in the public works committee
and and what's happened it didn't go to
transportation in the Senate was always
going to the public works it to the
capital budget committee
because it was a we were looking for
funds and we'd usually go into the
capital budget
when it came out of Public Works
so that's why
it didn't go to the transportation
committee
so that's that's a quick my quick
overview thank you and I would like to
emphasize that we're talking about
Freight rail on this Excuse me yes this
is doll Freight rail
um so that we don't get tangled into the
whole debate on passenger rail on this
um
is my understanding that with this
requests for the grant that there is a
requirement that we have it's a matching
money and that is the intention of
um St Lawrence and Atlantic to use money
that this body is already granted to you
for improvements of that rail line to do
the portion of that match that's quick
last capital budget we had five hundred
thousand from the state and 500 000 from
the St Lawrence Atlantic that will be
used as the matching Monies to get the
federal funds
thank you and that's why I wanted those
who are coming back to uh understand
what's going on with that
um
so
I
any questions from members of the
committee
Paul thanks for being here and the
information you provided uh can you just
I missed the first what was the weight
you're moving up to
286. what was the weight previously that
equation
two six no two two eighty threes we were
going up to 263.
three percent thank you
um seeing none and there was no
um
other business to come before us
um which was kind of surprising since
it's the last meeting before February or
March but it is what it is
um we cannot set a new meeting for this
uh statutory committee since it will be
up to the speaker and the Senate
President to appoint new members after
next week
um it will not be the highest priority
that either of them have since they have
to set the Committees in the house in
the Senate to deal with parking all
those little things uh before they worry
about statutory committees so I I would
wager even though it's illegal in this
state that it would probably be February
or March before this committee would be
called back into session by whomever is
um on that committee with that I want to
thank all of the members of the
committee especially those two who drove
down from the North Country for no
business
but thank you for coming down today and
but for all of the work that's been done
over the last two years on
um trying to keep the state on an even
Keel as far as the capital budget and
what we're doing with our facilities I
thank you for all of your work on that
and
with that
I adjourn the capital budget overview
committee for uh yes I would like to
thank you very much for your
chairmanship the committee over the last
two years uh and I know from it's a can
be a difficult job and I know that being
a previous chair it can be difficult but
thank you very much for your
professionalism and best wishes in your
future endeavors and hopefully we'll see
you around from time to time next term
thank you
I fully intend to give its
um
um but as I started to say
this meeting is adjourned subject to the
call of whomever gets appointed as
last official act John